boa tarde gente
meu nome é fábio brasa eu sou rapper
poeta e hoje eu vivo daquilo que eu amo
e muita gente até escuta minhas rimas e
falou e se mana devia ser mais estudioso
o cdf
mas na real era tipo pior aluno que se
poderia imaginar
pegava 78 recuperações era expulsa da
escola convidada a se retirar
minha mãe tinha que ir lá me indicavam
psicólogo psiquiatra falar tem que dar
remédio queria dar remédio pra mim mas a
minha mãe não ele não é imperativo em
casa ele livre e na real eu acho que
muito na escola é projetado para tirar a
criatividade da gente não tem muita
regra você tem que decorar as coisas pra
falar o que a professora quer escutar
então nunca não me sentia bem eu não via
propósito ali na escola né
foi quando eu descobri aquilo que eu
amava que eu descobri que eu podia
estudar também que eu também tinha
nascido para estudar acho que todo mundo
nasceu pra estudar só não tinha
encontrado aquilo que eu amava community
dizia quem tem um porquê pode suportar
qualquer como eu não viu porque na
escola mas aonde eu encontrei meu porque
foi no rap com samba na poesia isso fora
da escola aonde eu descobri o meu máximo
potencial criativo aonde eu vim porque
ele está estudando e alimentei a sede
por conhecimento
vou começar recitando um poema minha que
eu fiz já há muito tempo atrás ele é
tecnicamente muito simples mas ele fala
muito disse que falou assim sempre fui
um aluno cdf tirava c d e e f
há nem pensar de nem no pref
cada nota que saía me rende um tabefe a
e como eu sofria numa sala de aula
lembro que ali a vida não vale a pena me
sentia miserável aprisionado numa jaula
foi assim titular do garoto problema
me chamavam de imaturo me diziam tanta
asneira já pensa no seu futuro qual vai
ser sua carreira enquanto eu bom eu só
queria ser feliz mas sem saber o valor
da vida como queriam que eu soubesse o
valor de
x comecei a ler livros mas a lição não
fazia escutava os racionais mas não que
a professora dizia reprovei matemática
passou raspando em geografia e só
começava o meu ensino depois que o sino
batia foi no samba belo dia que a magia
aconteceu foi o ipp hop inutilizado que
eu descobri quem era eu nem cantina e
platão nem mitchell nem galileu
encontrei ali respostas que a escola
nunca me deu
descobri a minha ânsia insaciável por
conteúdo conteúdo que o sistema de
ensino assassina
mergulhei no meu estudo sem caneta o
canudo sem deixar bater do sino alterar
a minha sina
admito sem remorso passei de ano na cola
e grande parte do que se eu aprendi fora
da escola
meu professor foi meu avô dos meus
amigos da bola o gabriel o pensador noel
rosa o cartola foram os livros o pessoa
o paulinho da viola foi o zeca pagodinho
eo radinho mequetrefe foi o que o pac
dorival mano brown eo moses death deve
ser talvez por isso que eu seja tão cedo
a minha vida foi assim através do rap do
futebol do meu avô que era poeta
concreto eu fui encontrando o meu porque
acho que as duas coisas fundamentais que
me fizeram encontrar porque foi o
primeiro o meu avô
a referência poética dele e segundo a
minha convivência com outras realidades
então vamos começar meu avô meu avô era
poeta concreto é é amava samba e amava
livros e acho que toda criança precisa
de uma referência e eu via meu vou lendo
o livro e contando aquelas histórias eu
pensar por querer ser igual eu vou pegar
aqueles livros grossos assim machado de
assis levava no recreio da escola e
tentava ler professora chamou minha mãe
tá fazendo lavagem cerebral na mulher
que ele traz livro de machado de assis
na escola sete anos mas a referência do
meu vou me deu essa vontade de querer
ser igual a ele e por causa disso
comecei a escutar samba que eu vou amava
samba e cantava sambas antigos orlando
silva noel rosa eu era fascinado pela
rima já jogava bola gostava de samba
só que eu ouvia paixão com o coração
amor com dor de repente eu vou ver com
noel rosa seu garçom faça o favor
hoje me trazer depressa uma boa média
que não seja requintado um bem quente
com manteiga dessa guarda na um copo de
água bem gelada fecha a porta da direita
com muito cuidado que eu não estou
disposto a ficar exposto ao sol a
perguntar o seu freguês do lado qual foi
o resultado do futebol foi nossa pode
rimar tudo isso disposto a ficar exposto
rimas internas uma riqueza de rima que
foi então acho que dá pra começar a
escutar no rosa e tentar compor igual a
ele
fui aprender cavaquinho então eu vou
despertou essa sede de conhecimento pela
leitura pela poesia e pelo samba e
através disso eu comecei a estudar sem
saber que estava estudando lá na frente
só que eu fui ver que isso aí valeu pra
mim
a segunda coisa foi a minha a minha
convivência com pessoas de outras
realidades que acho que foi fundamental
eu jogava bola então através do futebol
eu tive a experiência de jogar né de
conviver e foi primeiro através de
futebol depois do sangue com pessoas de
realidades totalmente distintas cores e
classes sociais
pessoas do brasil inteiro então ali
quando eu entrei na divisão de base do
palmeiras para jogar bola
pela primeira vez eu tive esse choque
porque até então na escola onde estudava
não tinha pobre só escola privada não
tinha negro no clube que eu jogava bola
não tinha negro
a relação do rico pobre no brasil é
servil né só quando um está servindo à
convivência assim a convivência de igual
para igual do rico pobre só foi possível
pra mim dentro do campo de futebol
dentro da roda de samba dentro da roda
de rap e é muito louco porque puxa a
gente tem que ter isso a todo momento a
gente que o rico eo pobre tipo pegar o
transporte público junto tinha que
freqüentar os mesmos lugares porque
senão essa convivência não tem a empatia
geram muro um abismo social e cultural
um apartheid ea gente vê nitidamente
transitando pelos dois mundos como um
pensa que o outro é em um choque essa
polarização política muito diz
e ali dentro do campo de futebol eu
conhecia essas realidades e aquilo é um
filme a consciência
um jeito ué mas como assim
a brutalidade policial na polícia
bonzinha mas como assim todo mundo é
pobre quando tem dinheiro pegar o ônibus
mas como assim
eu não entendia essas coisas mas como
assim porque a maioria que é negro e
pobre porque eu tenho eles não têm isso
primeiramente me fez reviver 7 os
conceitos e preconceitos que eu tinha me
fez ampliar minha consciência social me
fez reconhecer meu privilégio e
reconheceu o privilégio é o primeiro
passo nós pra transformar a humildade e
pé no chão e me fez abominar certas
atitudes dos meus colegas do lado de lá
aí eu via certas piadas não achava mais
graça naquelas pelas mãos não tem graça
e eu comecei a me aproximar do rap
também muito daí porque o rap contava
essa realidade esse brasil que até então
ninguém tinha me contado 17 e se essa
história do brasil que a professora não
me falou nem minha mãe nem a televisão
certo era outra realidade que ali houve
por exemplo que o rap o samba me fizeram
em relação ao negro por exemplo eu só vi
se a tv escutasse o que as pessoas ao
meu entorno falam e só olhar se a onde
os negros estão localizados no meu
bairro no meu clube
a visão que eu tinha era de pena ou o
estereótipo do ladrão
ouvindo samba e rap eles viraram meus
heróis porque era o próprio negro
contando a história dele o ponto de
vista dele e aí meus heróis é o mano
brown era o cartola queria ser igual
eles e aí eu descobri por chama nessa
história que falam dos negros a mentira
eles são na verdade heróis da liberdade
os arquitetos maiores da cultura popular
brasileira tem que ouvir da boca dele
pra saber então várias coisas que me
desconstruir muito boa recitam 11 um
poema que o que eu falo porque você faz
rap seu playboy que eu bato muito nisso
e dentro da roda de samba de rap é
também visto que na roda de samba de rap
ninguém quer saber quem é seu pai na
balada com que roupa você chegou com que
carros e tava se sentar no camarote ou
não lá que é saber sabe jogar bola
sabe tocar um instrumento sabe a
história do samba sabe a história do rap
tem proceder tem disciplina chegou aqui
complementou geral
qual é o conhecimento dele mentalidade
de então tudo isso me fez virar homem
agora não dependo dos meus pais para
nada não vou chorar meu pai na escola
pra minha mãe aqui sou eu e eu fui me
descobrindo quem eu era que eu podia ser
independente de qualquer rótulo social
eu falo assim é porque você faz rap seu
playboy
você nunca sofreu na pele nem sabe
quanto à realidade dói porque você fala
da pobreza se vive na fartura que
defendeu os pretos mas não sabe o que é
ser um só se apropria da cultura porque
você faz rap seu playboy
você teve estudo teve tudo na sua casa
nada falta admitiu que não seria nem
metade se não fosse de classe média alta
eu faço rap não é porque eu gostei da
batida é porque a mensagem que ele
trouxe transformou a minha vida porque
na falsa realidade que eu vivia e foi
minha lanterna que iluminou o meu
caminho e me tirou dessa caverna eu faço
rap pois acredito que conversa com deus
toda vez que aperta o rec e assim como o
rap me transformou mas que transformar
isso em um negócio eu uso esse negócio
para transformar outros moleque eu faço
rap pois ele pulsa na minha veia na
minha artéria e quando a música fala
qual ela transcende a matéria
eu tenho consciência que nasci em berço
nobre num país onde mais de um terço é
pobre onde o preço sobe ea gente luta
para que algum futuro logre mas a vida
não vale nada pois nem o seguro cobre
enquanto muitos chapão mais a mente 19
eu boto uma rima inteligente em cada
estrofe para que a gente não move
praticamente filosofe para espantar a
zica que não sai com repelente off
oração mas são a nokia ea população que
sofre pois não têm acesso a combinação
do cofre educação resolve para quem teve
um bom colégio mas ensino por aqui não é
direito é privilégio sem fundamento
irmão e longe da grade de aulas vai
parar na fundação atrás da grade da
jaula e a taxa de mortalidade se encaixa
na baixa escolaridade você acha
fatalidade
o rap a nossa cultura nosso livro de
literatura que nos desafia ser um ser
pensante o rap é a escada para a criança
que não alcançou
lá em cima da estante com sua rima
possante fiquei em choque descobriu que
era uma ponte escutando brown e é de
rock headshot sem brincadeira daquele
instante em diante em minha mente abril
como uma brincadeira depois da onde eu
vivia eu não via tudo o que acontecia do
outro lado do conflito social e racial
que existia aos poucos eu percebia que
também era culpado o rap denuncia
tirania aula de sociologia com o índice
atualizado foi meu jornal falado sobre a
história de um brasil que até então
ninguém tinha me contado foi o rap que
ampliou o horizonte fez a ponte para
conversar com o outro lado da ponte que
fez com que a barreira do preconceito se
quebrasse juntou pessoas de todas as
cores e classes coisa que eu não via no
meu bairro nem na minha classe foi o rap
que me deu essa oportunidade de enxergar
a realidade de uma outra esfera e para
desfrutar desse roller não precisava nem
mostrar rg era só gostar de r a page era
ali naquela rota eu me senti mais eu me
senti em casa eu descobri quem era o
fábio braz a despeito de qualquer rótulo
social seu cartão de visita não é seu
cartão de crédito aqui não tem camarote
para dividir o pessoal todo mundo é
igual ninguém mais que ninguém não quero
saber o que você tem quero saber como
você vai agir
essa história de isso e sabe que eu sou
aquino cola vai ter que mostrar quem é
dentro da roda de frio e naquele momento
parei para refletir pô
imagina se o brasil todo fosse igual a
isso aqui e foi naquela roda em algum
canto do brasil que aquilo que a
sociedade separou o rap uniu o rap me
salvou mesmo não vindo da quebrada me
salvou de não ser mais um boy mente
fechada por isso não pode haver panela
do alphaville a favela bota um rap para
salvar essa molecada
só isso então é isso dentro da roda de
rima ea primeira vez que eu colei a roda
de rima em frente do metrô santa cruz
para batalhar eu colei para assistir e
de repente eu vi um cara com uma
prancheta e aí meu amigo falou lá dá
para se inscrever o seu nome na máscara
profissionals meu primeiro dia que foi
tá com medo eu fui lá botei meu nome
fui campeão todo mundo foi kaká que eu
sou boba
acabei voltando lá várias semanas
seguidas fiquei três semanas sendo
campeão e o elogio que recebi era mano
se tem muito conhecimento e muito
vocabulário
você tem o dom para isso aí eu pensei
caramba
então desde molequinho quando eu pegar
os livros do meu avô quando estava no
rosa e tentava escrever as letras
escutando poesia
aquilo ali foi uma escola pra mim então
estava virando o cdf para me tornar a
quem eu viria ser eu estava estudando
sempre foi estudioso só além da escola
que o irmão
então eu acho que é isso a gente precisa
ter um porquê da pergunta que eu deixa
qual é o seu porque né e quem tem um
porquê pode suportar qualquer como qual
é seu porque eu encontrei meu porque no
rap mas eu acho que cada um pode
encontrar seu porquê e devolver esse
porque de alguma maneira se eu entrar no
rap não devolver o privilégio de ter
tido um avô poeta de ter estudado nas
melhores escolas eu sei que eu critiquei
a escola mas quando a mulher que a gente
não percebe mas o tanto que eu aprendi
mesmo não há mesmo do mal tanto que
aprendi aprender outra língua
coisas que pouca gente no brasil
infelizmente pode ter então muito da
minha rebeldia descobri que não era
porque eu era um revolucionário época
era um moleque mimado certo e eu
descobri que era mimado quando eu fui
jogar no palmeiras vive lá os moleque
cortando 5 da manhã para ir treinar e
estudando a noite eu falei nossa caramba
como eu sou mimado então eu aprendi a
devolver essa rebeldia no rap tem que
virar homem onde eu posso devolver saiu
de onde faz a diferença não podia só
fiquem criticando no rap na poesia é
devolver meu privilégio então muita
gente vai discutir a escuta rima do
brasil e fala um ano comecei a gostar de
poesia por causa de você
o escutando suas lentes eu fui atrás de
livros depois que falava agora tomando
delivery ou por causa de você descobrir
que eu amava repto fazer um rap ou teve
um menino que mimi trombou na rua e
falou eu amava as idéias do funcionário
depois comecei a escutar seu rap eu eu
mudei agora
fazendo advocacia
tipo eu nem sinto ele na rima mas assim
é fazer a pessoa refletir é isso
entendeu essa é a minha missão é tem
moleque de 13 12 anos lado um trombo
moleque lá da bahia ele falou mano eu
aprendi a escrever por causa de você
posso cantar uma rima encanta e quando
ele cantou falei malu que daqui um ano
semi supera tinha como assim foi o que
influencia é sério mesmo
os técnicos poéticas que usava da poesia
concreta de fernando pessoa do meu avô
de repente ele viu em mim aquela
linguagem de português e começou a fazer
e logo mais ele passa ou seja tá cheio
de talento aqui no brasil a gente
precisa entender que o nosso material
humano é nossa é a matéria mais rica que
brota do nosso chão certo ea gente
precisa devolver esse investir nosso
povo que só assim com educação brasil
vai mudar até falo brasil só vai mudar
quando a nossa educação foi mais
premiada do que a delação certo
então é isso aí encontrar o seu porque e
devolver e de alguma maneira
estrapolando tempo que eles vão terminar
é porque eu acho que metade da vida é o
que a gente imagina e metade o que a
gente vê então a gente tem que imaginar
seja você a mudança que você quer ver
então vamos ver primeiro vamos sonhar
para tudo aqui um dia imaginando
miquelângelo pintou a capela sistina o
homem chegou à lua foi imaginando que a
gente montou quer dinheiro dinheiro uma
imaginação da mente imaginando que a
gente inventou religiões e civilizações
o brasil que é o brasil quem inventou
que isso é um país que se divide assim
tudo na nossa mente a gente pode
transformar imaginando esse mundo tem um
porquê uma utopia corra atrás dessa
utopia como diz mario quintana é não é
porque algo algo está distante
não é porque uma coisa está distante que
não é motivo para não querer las
que triste nosso caminho se não for a
presença distante das estrelas certo ea
utopia isso é o sol no horizonte
quanto mais você caminha mais um sócio é
fato você nunca vai chegar
então pra que serve pra isso pra
caminhar para frente certo tanto que
deixa de sonhar
a minha pra frente da mais nós que temos
o privilégio não é nenhuma escolha isso
acho que é uma obrigação moral devolver
lhe encontrar um porquê
[Música]